[Música]
en el donbass continúan los combates
feroces y las tropas ucranianas no
consiguen avanzar debido a la artillería
rusa en el centro de severodonezk el
presidente de lenski aseguró que el
costo humano de la batalla está siendo
aterrador en una nueva petición de armas
adicionales a occidente voy a las
batallas en el donbass seguramente
pasarán a la historia militar como una
de las batallas más brutales de europa
llamamos la atención de nuestros socios
a diario sobre el hecho de que sólo un
número suficiente de artillería moderna
para ucrania asegurará nuestra ventaja y
pondrá fin a la tortura rusa del donbass
ucranianos son tontos mientras el
gobernador regional de severodonezk
sostiene que todos los puentes para
salir de la ciudad han sido destruidos
cortando el acceso a los suministros e
imposibilitando las evacuaciones y que
entre un 70 y un 80 por ciento de la
ciudad está bajo control ruso pero que
aún no ha sido capturada tras meses de
bombardeos lo que queda está totalmente
destruido y los que quedan están con
pocos recursos y mucho puede llegar en
cualquier momento nunca se sabe cuándo
llega puede ser muy silencioso y luego
literalmente un golpe repentino y han
disparado cinco veces no hay agua ni luz
ni gas la conexión desapareció ayer
beirut unexpo cargo la toma de
severodonezk a supondría una victoria
estratégica para moscú que sigue
presionando para hacerse con el control
total del donbass al este del país una
región predominantemente de habla rusa
controlada en parte por los separatistas
pro kremlin desde 2014